So, you've chosen an app idea, you know
what features you're going to include,
and you also know which APIs and
libraries you're going to make use of.
So, now it's time to
make a paper prototype.
I like to do this using actual paper,
but you can also do it in Storyboard or
using Photoshop, or any number
of prototyping software suites.
Link to some in
the instructor notes below.
The point of this exercise is to define
how users will flow through your app.
And if you're drawing them by hand,
you don't need to be Michelangelo or
Davinci.
Just get your ideas down on paper.
Will they start with
a login in screen and
then move to a custom
set of user information?
Or perhaps they'll start
with a list of some kind and
then they can log in later to save it.
Now, you want to be as
detailed as you can here.
I mean,
what happens when a button is pressed?
And where are you going to
be pulling information from?
The more information that
you can include here,
in this paper prototype,
will help you down the road later.
As you may have noticed, user experience
plays a huge role in this step.
And if you'd like to think
a little bit more deeply about it,
Udasity has a great course
on user experience design.
It's called UX Design for
Mobile Developers.
Lessons one to three are what's
most relevant to us in this course.
So if you'd like a link to that class is
included in the instructor notes below
if you'd like to work through
some of those exercises.